en tant qu'acteur je fais semblant de gagner ma vie je
joue des personnages fictifs résolvant souvent des
problèmes fictifs
je crois que l'humanité a considéré le
changement climatique de la même manière que s'il
s'agissait d'une fiction
prendre des mesures, nous nous le devons,
mais plus
important encore, nous le devons aux
générations futures qui comptent sur nous tous [Musique
] le
changement climatique est réel,
il se produit en ce moment même, c'est la menace la plus urgente qui
pèse sur toute notre espèce
[Musique]
Je ne peux pas imaginer avoir un
dirigeant politique qui n'écoute pas la
communauté scientifique [
Musique]
nous ne devrions pas avoir des gens au pouvoir qui
ne croient pas aux faits et répliquent aux
vérités de la science moderne qui sont capables
de manipuler et de risquer l'avenir
de toute cette génération
[Musique]
vous